um how long have you been like actually
like really taking the music profession
serious like
um it was
right when I dropped out to in the
Philippines like right at that
transition like um right when I dropped
out I started making metal music like
full time
and then basically like I would say like
in the to the world's eyes where they
would say I took it seriously it's like
when I got to the states and started
trying to rap to sing so you're doing
like metal yeah like [__] like give
me like a comparison to the death core
technical death core technical death
metal brutal death core the whole death
Spectrum Jesus so would that be like
Slayer type [__] the um because I know
there's a bunch of sub genres yes
there's like industrial they're actually
right on the money because Slater Slayer
if it wasn't for them death battle
wouldn't exist right they're kind of
like the Run DMC of death metal
thrash metal they're thrashed yeah yeah
I don't even know so what's what's the
biggest death metal band
hmm I would say dying fetus I heard a
dying fetus yeah they Cannibal Corpse
Cannibal Corpse
them that [__] is have you ever heard of
uh
is it job for a cowboy Oh Yeah
not that legendary death core death
metal people still like you know debate
about this yo listen I was driving uh me
and my boy TK who's a producer of mine
who works with me and he we were driving
from Phoenix to LA in the middle of the
night he had to stay awake
and I was supposed to take a nap
so we swapped seats and he throws on
yeah job for is it drop her account for
a cowboy yeah
that's the kind of [__] you were making
oh my God that is crazy
yo I literally was like bro what the
[__] is going on right now like what is
even going on right now so you were
doing like that
wow yep [__] salute full time so you
were like you bet been in a lot of uh
like [__] mosh pits yeah
unfortunately
mosh pits are um they're fun I just saw
I mean I just saw Metallica the other
day and and obviously they're kind of
like not death metal they're quite the
opposite
but the pits still going on throughout
the whole like floor and I was like oh
this reminds me of high school right
yeah but I'm sure the pizza it goes
Death Metal Show are a little bit more
aggressive they're crazy it's like
there's a whole lot of like mental
stress that actually goes on with like
actually even the artist that goes into
it because it takes a different kind of
like a set of goop who would wanna see
like you know the violence ensue right
in front of their eyes yeah
that's actually what happens when even
the guitar just starts like damn
[__] everybody start swallowing oh my
God so is there a big scene for that in
the Philippines
pretty small pretty very very small
that's why when I started like kind of
grinding for it like I had to kind of
put like this layer on my figure like
how to approach the fan base because
because it would just be like
white boys like from here SoCal and in
Norway sometimes yeah yeah yeah there I
think there's a uh it correct me if I'm
wrong wasn't there a death metal band
that one of the members killed one of
the other members in Adam
um I don't know about or is that was
that or was that like a
they probably don't tell they use the uh
album art for they talking about yeah
Mayhem I don't know uh that's a black
metal actually black metal yeah black
metal that is that from Norway yeah yes
and there's a big band that's uh what's
the big band that's [__] yeah I think
it was Mayhem Mayhem the band Mayhem
they use the uh his bandmate's body took
a picture of it in his album art
yeah that's hardcore for real Madonna
see why you're into it man
yeah so how do you end up being this kid
who could dance and rap it what
uh
it was like
I've been
dad's just been kind of like an escape
thing growing up you know
like cause I'd be stressed out too much
stressing too much about school and like
all of the homework and and being at
home always getting scolded and
she was with my sisters like in in China
I was in the Philippines
and um yeah so a lot of the times like
at school I wouldn't be too good in like
you know the academic stuff but when
like PE go on like we got a project like
we need to do some dance thing all right
let's go right I'm like that type and
basically that's like kind of just been
what I doing but never took it like to
I did take it seriously
because like in Elementary in sixth
grade nonsense
fifth grade I I was actually doing dance
competitions with like some of my
classmates
and yeah but it was like on some real
thug and dance since like like how job
Milwaukee's could have came up but in
the Philippines yeah some real battles
but like some like you were like you're
like bandaged up from the mosh pick from
the night before yeah and then you had
to go and [__] yeah actually dance
yep that's crazy it's just a dope uh
pendulum you're on like you could you
did Death Metal and you were you know
dancing for real because you were Dan
you do you you had you got opportunity
to dance with the Jabbawockeez right yes
I actually
um had the opportunity to dance with the
ex-founders uh his name Phil Taya Phil
he was the one I um choreographer
choreographed my video for my song up
down which is out right now y'all can
check that out is that the song that I
call Eminem's attention yeah yeah